cuarta noche de protestas en españa a
medida que los manifestantes siguen
luchando por la libertad de expresión en
el país la violencia nocturna se desató
desde el inicio de las protestas el
martes en respuesta a la sentencia del
rapero pablo hasél condenado a nueve
meses de prisión por publicar trinos que
según las autoridades enaltecían al
terrorismo la condena dividió la
población y también al gobierno de
coalición con algunos miembros del
ejecutivo a favor de los manifestantes
existe además un amplio consenso dentro
de la sociedad española para amparar
mejor la libertad de expresión en línea
con la regulación que existe en otros
países europeos y el gobierno de españa
ya ha manifestado que va a mejorar la
protección legal de la libertad de
expresión en segundo lugar en una
democracia plena y la democracia
española es una democracia plena resulta
inadmisible el uso de cualquier tipo de
violencia no hay excepción a esta regla
no hay causa ni lugar ni situación que
pueda justificar el uso de la violencia
el viernes el presidente pedro sánchez
dijo que el uso de la violencia no se
puede justificar
la semana pasada el gobierno anunció que
cambiaría la ley para garantizar el
derecho a la libertad de expresión y
eliminar eventuales penas de cárcel no
obstante este cambio llegaría tarde para
la sentencia de hazel por lo que algunos
socios de la coalición del presidente
sánchez firmaron una petición de indulto
para el rapero encarcelado